mind your decisions I'm presto Walker in
a circle two triangles are inscribed as
shown with areas of s and T if s is less
than T what is the smallest value of 4 s
squared plus T squared all over 5 s T
this is from the 2018 Oxford maths
admissions test pause if you'd like to
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this problem
[Music]
when I tried to solve this problem I
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
a relationship between s and T we are
given that s is less than T and we know
both have to be positive because they
represent areas we also know T is less
than the area of the circle however
there's no bound on the area of the
circle because we don't know its radius
so what other relationship is there
between s and T well that's the tricky
part about this problem there is no
other relationship the geometry setup is
a big distraction you're supposed to
recognize this and solve for positive
numbers s less than T so let's minimize
this function for positive values of s
less than T well first simplify this
function dividing through by 5 s T we
get 4/5 s over T plus 1/5 T over s if we
let u equal s over T then T over s will
equal 1 over u we can substitute those
in and we get a function in one variable
U we will then take the first derivative
of this function which will equal 4/5
minus 1/5 u to the power of negative 2
this function will equal zero when u is
equal to 1/2 it'll be negative when u is
between zero and 1/2 and it'll be
positive for u greater than 1/2
altogether this means the function f has
a minimum at U equal to 1/2
therefore we substitute that value back
in and we get the answer which is 4 over
5 and this will minimize the function
that we want so the answer is 4 over 5
this is a lesson because typically you
have to use all the information given in
the problem but in this problem you're
supposed to recognize the geometry is a
big distraction
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]